welcome to this video and nesto Ron Don
when Azula Venezuela not too bad at the
moment with the flag gassing okay 92
yeah that's that's really uncommon in
the advanced and should I'm it's not
easy not sure what it okay I'm how to
see develop with Bishop e3 some what
this is okay I'll I'll I'll play a play
sharply try to to open up the position
ok I can even play you five here it is a
bit loose know if I do tell
hmm
I wonder I really wonder about the
stability here is there some way to use
is somewhat to somewhat mega-development
with them with quick play here I don't
know and some spend too much time
already yeah this wasn't really
necessary okay I caught up a bit caught
up a bit on the clock is one of those
instant movers just play every move
instantly must be good ok let's see is
taking e6 twice ciao and that's not a
very good position that i have here
despite is a very quick play it's not
really not really good ok let's see the
special up here is the typical problem
not sure what this is doing really okay
maybe wants to go Bishop f4 word i can
take it your form ok ok now I'm fine
again of course if I get this exchanged
oh no no black is even better get the
night to you for check it's very nice of
awesome ok just do one DF I'll look at
one is this is this is a very bad end
game now check question is can I
immediately win the spawn probably not
so I just I just get over here try to
fix more pawns on dark squares I is
ignoring all that ok ok this is now
fixed on the dark square I only need to
attack the pole now and win the win it
let's see b6 on probably how to make any
progress without it the night does not
have squares this is of course but we
add
yeah I don't like to play five real name
yeah maybe I must to do that to put him
in zoosk wrong here
yeah I'm getting the night here it's not
really it's not sure that it's really
helping me much and Chuck
now that they cannot win this this is
this is frustrating really I cannot win
this yeah okay
maybe maybe I can try to get the king
over you cannot take a five at the
moment I don't see how we could do that
with the Bishop c5 maybe now I win this
pawn time warning
I only hope Yang's don't trap this night
somehow check check check check check
draw offered check
check check check check check check
check check game haha just a couple of
moves ahead and I needed to do so many
pre moves here and yeah that's the
wonder of the pre move with ten seconds
ah but what the real question is yes
endgame here must be really good for
black and die I really spoiled this
preview maybe I did I shouldn't do that
this moves on the King side which which
are in general helpful but it's probably
not the the right way to play I don't i
don't know maybe it is a draw I mean
it's possible it's a bit a bit a bit
unfair but it's just a draw but probably
is yeah yeah it's hard to hard to play
without a five I mean check alright this
is really just a draw i can only shuffle
around the around here you must be must
be cautious
and maybe it is still a draw but now it
does there are some some slight chances
of course the one problem is i can try
to get the night 2 2 2 f 3 but I I
forgot about this move mm-hmm this what
was the winner I was always only
thinking about here and then he has the
f porn okay that's that's really
interesting I mean this is just an easy
win but here there are some interesting
points let's say this move yeah and then
then i have this resource interesting
look at this gap and threatening to
promote you must go here and then this
is a win i get the this is too far apart
if he wants to keep this pawn I march
the deep bone and you cannot stop both
this is just dead wood here very cool so
95 want to move ok King takes is
immediately over so we must take here
and that this is really
probably winning probably so this is
what happened okay I can win all the
time with night everyone but I didn't
see that oh here here I computers
computer chess this is winning a funny
bit circumstantial because of this
double threat and he again he cannot
take because it promotes but okay I was
I was really down on time and now this
is a draw it seems Jack Jessee so we
know why this one check check I can I
get it to reform okay okay care from
check cause I had eight second year so
check I want to check I was content with
the draw was cooking if always better
yeah now this is relatively is even
sounds like I get all the pawns that was
close to make it with pre moves check
check check check yeah I wanted to
secure the draw at least getting rid of
the pawns and okay funny funny game
thanks for watching